I would like to share
a story that is related with my previous
role so I was a cloud architect
specializing in big data and AI still
within Microsoft but in my origin
country in Poland and the role was
imagine Consulting so I was Consulting
different customers different partners
like global companies
without mentioning the name and
imagine I had a call
I was asked to consult one AI solution
that time I didn't came up shared that
I'm lesbian with my team but that was a
call with a customer so like with a
partner and a customer I'm joining and
then
they are asking me to design solution
that will identify
lgbtqi plus people from the videos
because the government would like to
know how many those people are present
in some on some protest to take some
actions so I ask like what is why why
this dear customer would you like what
are you going to do with this
information right are you going to help
those people to grant them some price
then yes of course I will help you but
maybe not you know you want to track
them and they said of course we want to
know how many of them is there just to
know to put the proper solution so if
the 80 percent of LGBT people will will
bring soldiers they will do you know
cleanups shortly so I was you know on
teams okay let me think about that let's
post next please uh it takes me
a couple of like minutes to after the
call to process what happened of course
I didn't like quickly realize what was
said but then I quickly report that to
my manager who was that time in France
that you know this happened and I think
that
still we we love to design Solutions Ai
and bring more AI more and more at the
same time we have some initial design of
responsible AI where that time it was
three years ago right now we are talking
all the time about responsible Ai and
Frameworks that time no no it wasn't
that but I said I know that this is big
customer it's a government duh like
paying a lot but I think that we
shouldn't do that and he was digging why
like of course why like because it's
break like causing more harmful for
people and of course that time I came
out that it touched me because
I'm lesbian so on the protest again the
government for example out the
abortional anti-something whatever our
beliefs are I will be tracked and some
force will be used against me so uh
within a day I got the reaction all the
chains up to top that uh no like this
dear customer we are we are not going to
do that because it's unethical
secondly dear customer we have to review
all the projects that we are doing with
you because
um maybe some like that was me maybe
there would be another architect that
would agree on that uh and then that was
the immediate Direction and thirdly we
started to discuss and train globally
everyone about responsible AI that we
are going to verify like design but
before designing we are going to check
how the solution is going to be us Pro
Humanity or against
so that was a case of a lie for everyone
thank you thank you Sarah there was very
meaningful thank you for sharing this
story
this thing I wanted to find a mentor to
help me to now Arena could you put them
one of my biggest objective was to find
a mentor to help me navigate through the
corporate world
that is something they never teach you
in school
who do you go to how to make friends
especially a person of color so I went
into the mom's project it's a style for
women who are in Tech and they help you
get you know if you if you're needing
some training and classes and things in
Google so they help you provide that
also mentor and I got a wonderful Mentor
she lives in in Canada
but she was a mother and she's a manager
so she it was really great and she I
really wanted someone who was
African-American so they had gone to
stand some of the issues I go to but she
wasn't she was a white lady but she
understood and so we we create our
relationship and it was really great
because I could understand
how I approach people how relationships
are made some of the bias that I will
face as African-American and she
empathize so I guess her affirmation
that I didn't think I were able to get I
got some really good relationship and
advice so that part helped me to
navigate help me to understand how do
you make relationships how you look how
you spot biasm it's okay it's not about
you it's about the other person still be
able to be on your game plan even though
there's obstacles that you confront and
when I was getting my engineering degree
I got supported by two women who did not
have a high school education but they
sold so much they were there to help
support me as I was getting my dual
engineering degree and so
sometimes the person the person who
knows at least gives you the most help
gives you the most support gives you the
most love so I don't think it on color
don't rank it I'm just break it on
relationship what kind of relationship
have you formed and what can you get and
what can you give and so I've had these
two amazing people three amazing people
have been in my corner and been able to
support me and talk real they just put
it out there and I think that's what we
need
green I think I'm gonna have a really
hard time going after you each time
because I just want to sit here and ask
so many more questions about your
experience and it's really making me
think about just thank you
um I'm going to share an example that
just happened this morning as I
mentioned I work for Amazon and so we
have a paper writing culture at the
company and I've been working on writing
a paper for an idea that I have for some
time now and I've just been struggling
to understand who how do I get an idea
that I think is a good idea in front of
the Right audience and when is it ready
to get in front of that audience how do
I know and it feels hard it feels big it
feels like maybe I get shut down
and so to test the waters I'd kind of
been shopping around this paper with
with some peers and I said can you
pre-read for me can you give me your
feedback I'm trying to improve I'm
trying to learn and this morning someone
who I had done this pre-read test
reached out to me and said hey just I
heard somewhere somehow that our skip
skip is actually interested in this
topic and I think if you reached out
right now it would be a good time to
share your idea because it's clearly at
the top of their mind they want to know
more about it and it was such a it seems
like a small thing but it felt huge to
me this morning to just have someone do
one recognize like I see that you have
an idea you've put time into developing
it and here's your window to step up and
I'm going to give it to you I'm going to
encourage you to just go for it and
support you through it
um and I followed up with questions they
help me answer them and now I have a
meeting scheduled and so it's just it
was such a small thing but I think it
reminded me that being an ally doesn't
have to be big and those things that are
small can make such a big difference to
someone else even if you think you're
just doing a tiny thing like sending a
slack message about something you heard
in the hallway so
thank you thank you all of you for
sharing with those this very
meaningful stories so to move on I'm
going to start up with Julia
what is an example what examples have
you encountered where an ally has good
intentions intentions but bad outcomes
and how do have those situations have
been corrected
ooh so many to pick from
um
recently I had a manager who when I
interviewed with him I had mentioned I
you know was looking for bigger work
where I wanted to own a project and I
wanted to like architect it and I wanted
to help Shepherd it through to launch
and I and I felt that I was ready for
that and that I had almost done that in
a number of cases I'd you know acquired
other peoples and projects and and stuff
like that but I wanted something that
was fully mine and he was like yeah I
think we we have the opportunity for
that here so I joined the company
and a few months later I got invited
accidentally to a meeting and thought
hey I know I have a great idea and I put
together a proposal on here we can
create this series of microservices and
we can like take this crazy ass excuse
my language monolith that we have and we
can like break it up and and you know
this is just one step and a great way to
start it because it doesn't actually
touch all this other stuff it's sort of
a proof of concept and and he thought it
was a great idea took the took the
proposal up the channel it got approved
by our VP and it came back down and he
says he announced it to the team Julia
is going to lead this
yeah we can see where this is going
um the team was not sold on the idea
they were primarily not sold on me is
what I eventually discovered
um
I had a one-on-one one one afternoon
with one of my co-workers because I had
been doing that with a bunch of them
trying to figure out you know how does
this Corporation work how you know it's
a startup but how do we work what's what
are the real back channels and he
basically told me your project will fail
I will insure it
will not go anywhere even if you finish
it I was like oh nice
okay
moving on well
I didn't know he didn't know that was
actually his last day at the company
um that was
that just happened out of chance
but after this discussion I went back
and looked at a lot of code that the
team had been writing
and found
I mean sabotage might be a little bit
harsh but literally we had not been all
on the same page and it could easily
have been said that we weren't on the
same page because
there was miscommunication there was
disagreement there was people who really
didn't want to work with me on this
um you know I worked really hard to like
try all the things we try let's give
people more say in what the project is
let's talk to them and find out what
their concerns are
I went round and round in circles and we
also lost one of our employee somebody
found a job and was leaving the team as
well and so we were now like perilously
understaffed and so the solution to the
problem was was not actually my Ally at
all my boss because he was actually
quite useless because he felt that all
of this was a reflection on me
um so I actually brought to him the fact
that I had a friend who was a consultant
and had you know a team and we had
talked about some ways to be more
effective and efficient and
I also talked to our VP who had
greenlighted this project and actually
now had
some stake in it because he wanted it to
succeed I didn't tell him that there was
a little Mutiny going on the team but I
did tell him that we were having some
resource issues and suggested that I
know a friend who has this company and I
assume we can't afford them and all but
whatever so he goes give me the give me
the card so I gave him the card
and lo and behold he managed to get
funding for it so we were able to
augment my team with two and eventually
three Consultants to actually do the
bulk of the implementation of the team
so the the engineers on the team who
really didn't like the idea and weren't
working with me but working against me
they were just given other housekeeping
tasks to do and so I with the help of
these Consultants managed to launch
approximately on time
um and and actually we had a really
great launch there was no issues
whatsoever really and
yeah it was it was very interesting
um
it was very hard but I really
appreciated the opportunity that he gave
me even though he really sort of led me
to a swamp
idea outcome wasn't what he
no the outcome you know the outcome
wasn't what he expected it wasn't what I
expected but
um you know with a little Ingenuity and
some some help from some friends like
people I used to work with who worked at
this consultant some allies allies from
outside of the organization were able to
come up with ideas and drum up some
solutions that we were able to sell and
make happen so it was a different allies
that solved my problem but it was still
great
thank you thank you for sharing and
Crystal
um the question would be what actionable
act advice
actionable advice do you have for
someone who is trying to increase
understanding in how to be a genuine
Ally
I guess for me
um it would just be to sit and talk to
people
I think
um like someone mentioned earlier you
have no idea uh I think of Shivani who
mentioned you have no idea how a little
bit of information really really goes a
long way
um a piece of advice like a piece of I
am sitting on the board of like a
computational woman black computational
women in computation biology sorry and I
just happened to come across some Grant
and I was like oh yeah yeah here's a
grant you guys should apply to right it
was it took literally less than I
wouldn't say a minute of my time and I
was like here you guys go and they got
it and it was like the most money
they've ever had they're so excited
right and so it's just really chatting
with people really like giving them that
bit of information and just really just
taking the time I think another thing
that really helped was when I was going
from my postdoc to getting into the data
science field I ended up meeting a lot
of people through meetups and they took
pity on a postdoc and paid for my beers
and chatted with me about getting into
the field of data science and you know
those those guys made white men made a
lot of impact on me because you know
they just sat and chatted with me and
they were like yeah you can totally do
it like let's talk about your skill set
ping me if you need some advice and you
know it it didn't require much besides
like them chatting with me for 30 30 or
minutes to 60 minutes and them being
very nice and paying for a beer but that
was it right but they made a huge impact
on my life and that's what they had to
give to me so I would just say like just
Reach Out chat with people be open and I
think it will go much further than you
think it will
and for the Allies like what would you
recommend for the Allies allies to how
can
how can approach us like
um oh vice versa how to approach
I I guess it would be
maybe I'm being like what actions and I
like could do
for them to to make a starter
relationship with those minorities yeah
okay
um
maybe I mean I
I think it would just be to find some
commonality if somebody else has any uh
ideas that would be great but I would
honestly just think hey this person
seems has really cool shoes maybe that's
something I can start chatting with like
start something small that's how I
generally start with relationships at
work something super small and then I
grow it from there I I I think that's
how you do it but if anybody else feels
the need to
have any other advice I think being
friendly and kind right really that it
is that's where it starts and um
as an ally I have found that sometimes I
have to put my curiosity
under the table for a while like
literally I just want to get to meet you
or get to meet someone and say like
we're like maybe curious about so what
are you doing you know like you know and
things like that but like it's weird for
me to come up and say how can I help you
what kind of advice do you need like
that is is not really I think helpful
when you meet someone I think in order
for an ally to be effective
um they kind of have to need they have
to kind of have a relationship with
their target they're I don't know their
their friend this other person right and
it needs to be more of a
an Even Stevens
right like you need to want help before
me before I offer help otherwise
having been on the receipt receiving end
of help that I didn't really want and it
means me finding a way to be polite and
nice to say no thank you without pissing
off my Ally and that can be really
tricky
anyone has an a take over this yeah I I
like
um I guess to use a pnw term uh like it
has to be very like organic you know you
uh like you meet someone uh at a
conference right and and
um you you want to be an ally to them
start start a conversation on some
something super small right
um cool shoes or or hey you know like I
I really this lunch was amazing uh you
know like I don't know we're in the pnw
like are you vegan I don't know whatever
whatever that might be but you start
that conversation at a really basic
level and then listen you know listen to
to like the the Nuance in the answer
right when someone says oh thanks yeah
and then they continue talking listen to
what they're saying how they're saying
it
because that that provides a lot of
context into who that who the person you
are hoping to be allies with is right
and yeah I agree Julia you have to keep
your your curiosity I mean asking
questions is okay but keeping your
curiosity sort of like a at a medium you
know because
um we're not like we're not an
encyclopedia right like you can ask me
about Guatemala but I'm not a historian
on Guatemala
but you know like
we can talk about I don't know something
cool to do if you visit but if you want
to talk about like the political
situations like do your own research
talk do you know what's it like to be
Latino do the research read some books
but if you want to talk about like how I
like my interactions or what my life is
as a Latina in technology then then that
we can talk about but started off like
something super super organic something
that like we have in common not just
like
so I noticed your brown
Latina like what you know yeah okay
thank you
thanks uh concrete so I will say I think
a good opening question we're at a
conference like this is what brings you
here today you're not making any
assumptions about the person based off
of their race gender uh how they present
anything like that you're just asking
why what brings you here and then that
person can then lead conversation this
goes both ways you're not starting a
conversation with someone thinking
you're going to be the Ally and you know
they need your help it's that's a
problematic mindset but it's just about
meeting people and once you have that
open-ended question which is concrete
what brings you here today listen to the
cues that they're putting into that
response are they here because they're a
student and they're looking to meet
people are they here because they're
seeking a job opportunity are they a
speaker so
um hopefully that helps just one one
thing
do your homework
do your homework do the research you
know ahead of time whoever's coming
whatever your passion is if they have an
article that you're deep dive into you
really have a passion do your homework
and so when you go and approach that
person you can say wow you know I heard
you speak about censors and I'm really
into centered or I have you know some
and you can have a conversation but do
your homework do the research uh plan
ahead of time when you come to a
conference find out what area you're
really interested in and you might well
I reach out before the company say hi I
know you're going to be at the
conference I'm really excited to listen
to whatever topic I'm excited about and
then when you see them you have
something that establish a relationship
and you guys can talk and then you can
say hey can I get a card and then
respond you know I really enjoy meeting
you I hope maybe we can continue to
correspond and then you have formal
relationship but be
deep dive into whatever you are
passionate about you'll be amazed there
are so many people who are passionate
about what you are passionate about so
do your homework it's really important
to do your homework you'll be amazed how
many friends I love being at the airport
I'm from the south so it's that it's
very hard for me to make friends the
hardest part is just not like your
because if you're an elevator don't say
anything people walk you in a little bit
nobody's saying anything like good
morning oh good morning how are you
doing I'm I'm doing fine so do your
homework do the research what do you
like what really excites you why are you
in this field you know well you're
willing to give your all in this
particular whatever you is because
that's what drives you that's what makes
you what you like to do and then when
you reach out people will come to you
gravitate to you because it is the same
you share the same interests that they
have
so do your homework
to to as my two cents
because I'm thinking about happy hours
that are coming and you know another
three hours and so I'm not just thinking
about the conference but in general uh
the approach towards Elijah for me it's
like kind of a how to be inclusive so
sometimes I don't have to talk with
someone else because I just feel the
energy all just the point is that I
accept you whoever you are unless you
are not harming me
but I I'm taking you with you know
everything what you look and what you
are doing what you are saying so the
point is that you don't have we don't
have to talk during the happy hours I
would love to but just you know be
gentle to each other curious if we can
talk uh I'm like Again part of a being
inclusive is just to be curious about
you but about everyone
but just let's accept each other kind of
a share kind of a human love not the
romantic way but in a way of accepting
us like everyone
in in the shape that we are
okay thank you so much for sharing and
I'm going to
move with I event
what would be the best way that you call
workers could better Express a
commitment to diversity and inclusion
um that's that's a super important
question
um and I've I've been fortunate in um
and having some really amazing
co-workers uh and who are committed to
diversity and and Equity
um and then of course inclusion so I
guess the whole d e and I
um
and I think what is most important is
the
um their desire or their ability to
really put themselves out there uh while
being
um Advocates right it's it's more than
just oh I'm I'm part of the ERG right
I'm I go to the meetings once a month
and I you know go to the happy hours
it's it's more than that it's setting up
um fundraisers it's going to events for
uh for non-profits right it's it's
attending conferences it's um like
advocating
um with management for funding to host
um you know events like this one or or
other conferences that are that are
centered around Dei
and I think that's that's the most
important thing
um that that you want or or what you
would like or what I would like to
continue seeing from co-workers
um you know that that advocacy that
desire to
take that extra step not just wear the
shirts or you know put the backgrounds
on their team's Channel
um but really actually do the work
thank you thank you a bit we are going
to move with the estera
what are some specific ways that you
have
advocated for change
and the successes the and challenges
that you face it
all the stuff
so
to connect it connect that as it was in
the past once the case with this
response API happened I started to form
the energy or for gleam community so
glimmy's lgbtqi Plus at Microsoft in
Poland and at the beginning I like I
created Alias so I have energy now I
need people so I talked to some some of
them and one my colleague joined so
we're just two and it was like it was
spring and during summer we have a pride
parade in Warsaw that time it was Sprite
like Warsaw and Kiev because of the
because of the world so like a lot of
people were going there a lot of
companies a lot of logos of the
companies but I wanted to be sure that a
lot of people within the company will
also join this event
so I started with you know
Communications meetings
creating this this group convincing
people let's be vocal let's you know
discuss that and at the beginning that
was
like honest comments that yeah we have a
lot of urges like we have a lot of work
so maybe yes I I will join but uh you
know
um everyone said that we'll join In A
team's event I could like Outlook event
I could see that like uh 200 people is
coming but at the end I knew that like
if half of them will be on this event it
would be a huge success
and during a couple of weeks we have
been fighting printing t-shirts
convincing peoples of the groundwork
that to be an ally during that day so
celebrating being different celebrating
diversity celebrating celebrating
inclusion also celebrating happiness
because it's just a happy parade we have
to be there and there is no excuses like
oh I have a like give it no no I like
proper briefing three months before you
knew that the event is coming so at the
end there was a group of uh
70 people that came up I know that some
of them were just at the beginning and
they say by picture done and they went
home but the point is that because of
this Grand work talking with everyone
convincing that we have to be visible
this one day because it will help us to
build the group The the support group
it's important and you have to be there
so it finished like in a positive way
but a lot of challenges that I think
that every group diverse group will have
to have to find but there is a like
purpose
thank you Arena
how can we invite and maintain more
allies in our into our Network
I think reaching out
being getting involved
um
stating things to maybe come in interest
or coming concern help you to invite
allies help you to create allies help
you to Mentor Our Lives it's all about
relationship I think Maya Angelou say
the best to say is not what you say
about how you said when when I leave you
what do I feel what impact do I feel
that you on the words that you put out
so it's really important your words
and how it impact people
so you know meaning if you have harsh
words and someone come and smack you
it's and I'm sorry it's just comma it's
common people so having that that we're
making relationship you know that's the
most important part of anything working
with your co-workers what kind of
relationship you can assess some people
are extroverts some people are
introverts so you have to meet them at
that at that level you know some people
need Coca to bring out what you know
what they want to say so you kind of
have to wear a lot of hats and you have
to assess the situation but the most
important part you I will hope that you
want to leave is something a positive a
positive impact or whoever you meet
you know and a simple hi how's your day
goes a long way
you have no idea how that person will
come back and say hey how you doing or
the avoidance seeing you because they
don't want to say hi how you doing but
either way you have made the first move
it's like playing chess somebody got to
make the first move and whatever that
second move is
you have no clue but you have made the
first positive movement that's most
important
for Shivani as a new mother in Tech what
advice would you give to our our
audience regarding how to help mothers
feel supported in the workplace
great question many thoughts
um first in general becoming a parent
and uh we already have not very many
women in technology so the odds that you
work with a pregnant person actively are
very slim because it's also a very small
phase in life for most people too you've
got like a 10-year window of with a
co-worker maybe even and there aren't
very many of us
um fortunately now I think partners are
a lot more vocal too about the impact it
has and as a demographic we're all
moving up there and so it's becoming
more common so the odds of interacting
with someone who's going through this
live phase are getting up there but what
I found was that
um
lots of people that I work with are
still very young and very early careers
so through no fault of their own have
absolutely zero exposure to a friend
group a peer anyone who has ever been in
the position of being a parent except
for maybe their own parents and and
that's the phase in life that they're in
their recent College grads and that's
that's totally okay and normal and so um
I think and I was in that boat I
remember being in that boat and I'm like
I don't understand how hard this is or
what the challenges this person are
facing are
um and so I think the first thing is to
if you're comfortable and you have that
relationship with whoever in your life
is going through becoming a new parent
ask how they're doing which is a very
basic question if they're the person who
is the pregnant person they might not be
doing very well once you know that
they're pregnant and so that's it's like
just a nice thing to do to check in on
people and I I know it sounds simple but
even as a woman before I went through
this experience I don't think I really
understood like I I don't know if I
properly supported my pregnant people
until I saw them go through it and other
pregnant people around me and so I hope
this helps and I hope sharing my own
ignorance helps too
um and then the other thing I think you
can do is learn alongside
the people that are working with you
what the policies in your workplace are
to support this person ask questions
about their their plan if they feel open
to it and again this is very personal so
you have to have that relationship and
you have to guess how things are being
recepted back to you if someone seems
close don't push of course but
um what I like to encourage other moms
in technology to do is if they're
willing to be as vocal as possible about
the experience if you're someone who's
comfortable with it you're comfortable
sharing what your experience is like
then please do share I think that's what
we can do to help our allies learn
because otherwise we're all just kind of
poking around in the dark and it doesn't
help if you don't know what someone is
going through so I manage a team I've
been feeling unwell recently so I told
them I've been feeling unwell for
example it's a small thing but it's true
and it makes it hard to show up
sometimes for a 6 30 a.m morning with
full energy and the enthusiasm that I
should have I'm not going to let my team
down but it's okay to share that you're
not at a hundred percent and then coming
back from maternity leave
um I I really struggle to share how hard
it was for me in the moment and so I
think that's a really critical time is
for the birthing person and the
non-birthing person in when they're
coming back as a co-worker check in on
them frequently see how they're doing
look for flags that they are maybe sleep
deprived not doing well and if you feel
comfortable help advocate for that
person to your manager or your peers or
whoever ask how can I help do you need
any support right now it's a really
challenging time for many people for
various reasons feeding challenges being
sleep deprived is a classic thing but
there's a whole Suite of other things
that could be going on in the background
in terms of what those folks are dealing
with returning to work and so
um I think those are those are just a
few and you know afterwards if anyone
has any specific questions I'm happy to
answer them and be kind of an open book
that was super insightful for people who
are about to get pregnant or who are new
mothers thank you for sharing that and
we are going to do another round for the
whole panel and the question is what
gender is specific challenges
stereotypes or barriers have you had to
overcome during your career and we start
from Julie
I am a petite Asian woman I am five feet
tall
maybe with heels actually no without
heels but
um
I for a very long time looked very very
very very very young
very young
I had a really hard time being taken
seriously
and being heard
unless someone backed me up
and so if my manager introduced me in
the meeting and you know people in the
room knew who I was and a little bit
about my background and why I was there
it was fine
if I showed up and I didn't get
good Ally support
and I look around the room and say like
Ally support as in yeah that's Julia she
knows what she's talking about
um somehow you don't say it explicitly
that way right
um yeah I had one of the engineers on
the first team I worked on call me girl
for two or three months before I called
him Grandpa because I was so pissed
I don't recommend that I don't think it
was the I did not deal with that well I
will be very blunt with you
um but it was interesting because I got
to know him really well afterwards we we
actually had a discussion after that
little tiff there and he was a great guy
and he was really supportive and he just
he
I looked like 15 so I get kind now that
I'm 55 I get where he was right but
that's just not appropriate
um and it's always been really
challenging for me
um that's why I let my hair go Gray
because I will have to tell you like I
still was having a hard time being taken
seriously in my late 30s and 40s until I
stopped coloring my hair
um
I don't get it
right like I'm the same person
regardless but unless someone thinks I'm
not too young whatever that means
um
it was hard it's it's interesting now
that I'm on the other side of the fence
um
my oldest is 22. I have worked with a
number of co-workers who are my son's
age or younger and
I have to stop and remember what it felt
like for years and years and years
to be treated differently
because I looked Young
and so people underestimated me anyways
um yeah that's on top of being a woman
and all the other stuff maybe maybe not
I don't know it's hard to tell what is
actually it but um I I very much felt
for I'm gonna obviously this is a hot
spot for me because I'm gonna say
um this is this is a thing that really
got to me because I felt unheard I felt
like I had to express things and then
unless my unless Alex my co-worker
actually repeated what I had suggested
the meeting didn't didn't discuss my my
proposal right or my suggestion but when
Alex mentioned it yeah everybody would
talk about it because he he thought it
was a good idea
um yeah I think though it's I don't
experience that really anymore
thankfully you're very common I don't
know if I've overcome it or whatever it
is
um but I do I will say that it's
interesting because I've noticed that
because of that experience I am very
much more conscious of how I treat
um
my younger co-workers right like I don't
I don't I won't say early career because
there's plenty of career changers in
this field
um but a lot of times especially with
younger people whom I work with I try
really hard to find the way to
um respect them but also meet them where
they're at so that I have some
commonality with them and their current
experience
um and and then remember not to treat
them like my kids
thank you and
it's the same question thank you so much
yeah I guess
um just thinking back there are a lot of
times I think too numerous to count I
think
um one of them was I I was giving a talk
during my PhD and I was the only
African-American during a panel or not a
panel but it was like a series of talks
and I had a very distinguished scientist
come up to me and was like oh how was it
on a diversity talk and I was like
pretty sure I was the only black person
there but okay
um so you know there's a lot of times
when people just dismiss my actions
um and I think uh in terms of just my
development and progression through my
career I've also had a lot of things
where people were like try and put me in
a box so honestly I think my
stubbornness has worked out extremely
well if you tell me I cannot do
something I will do it like I had one
person in college tell me I bet you
cannot be without cough coffee for two
months and I did it and it was horrible
and then I I said okay here it's done
and then the day right after they said I
acknowledge you're not addicted to
coffee because you were able to stay
away I was like great and I just chugged
a ton so I have taken that wonderful
stubbornness with me to my job so if
somebody says like oh no I don't think
you can do this I will I will do it so I
think that's how I have dealt with it is
just and it's exhausting I'll be honest
it'll it's exhausting to do that versus
other stuff like during my PhD you know
what I did on the weekends besides cook
for fun I took courses online courses I
taught myself how to code I went through
like extra statistical courses in the
morning I get up I sit there and I read
a ton of blogs at night I sit there and
practice a lot of different modeling
like this is what I do in my free time
because
I keep getting underestimated and that's
the only way I know how to get around it
there yeah I mean there there are a lot
of a lot of
um
memories or or moments where
um you know the the second guessing and
I I think for me
um
it's
it's always I think the most triggering
perhaps or the most like upsetting is
when uh my
uh navigation of language or my code
switching uh is is like
um
I guess a shock to to people
um I was on at the time I was the
national
program Manor yeah the national program
manager for a non-profit
um and I was speaking with tech
companies about our upcoming conference
and
um yeah and and I was talking to to them
about the programmings that the programs
that we ran
um the the way that we were being more
inclusive by
teaching some of our programs or some of
our lessons in in Spanish and that we
had volunteers come to events to
translate or or speak in Swahili and
like different languages for the
population of girls that were coming to
our events and
um
and one of the the presumptive
um managers of a company that was going
to sponsor
uh just just sort of made a comment uh
like oh well it's it's amazing how well
your your English comes off
um I you know when when you were
mentioning Spanish and you said those
those words in Spanish it was just
perfect Spanish and your English I can't
even tell there's a there's an accent
there
um and it you know it's just so
frustrating
um because it it's
I I'm I'm bilingual well I'm I'm more
than bilingual but but that means that
doesn't mean that I'm half-assing
language or or you know and it it it
means that I understand that I I can
communicate in in two languages it
doesn't mean that I'm you know that I
can't communicate or and and I'm not
like something for you to like oh wow
you know for you to question also I'm on
a national like I'm speaking to you
about a national level conference and
like why do you think bring something
like this up is is appropriate
um so I think that is perhaps one of the
most frustrating ones of of the many
um but that yeah
um I don't know how to come out of that
one so
you came up with excellent yeah
so I love what you you said as
it really very similar in my case
um
that uh I studied as a bachelor
electrical engineering knowing that the
route like the background of computer
science is electrical engineering but it
was kind of a complex issue for me that
I was feeling that I will never be a
good programmer without finishing
computer science at the same time I
started to work at the same studying
full-time and working full-time just to
have money to survive and the the bias
that I was always hitting was that I'm
energetic nice but young I'm too young
to like that everyone like my boss or
other colleagues are taking what I'm
saying in a serious way even though I
was working with some like millionaires
doesn't matter leading project doesn't
matter uh always I was somehow
categorized as a geeky girl that can or
kit that can do coding and let's put
their leave her there and my strategy
was okay I will show you okay so for
Mastery I'll choose computer science
then I run away from the problem so I
switch Corporation to another and
another and another so at the end I
finish like master from computer science
and it was not enough because the same
pattern people are not taking serious
what I'm saying and I was speaking
polish that type like I'm speaking
speaking but the native language so I
was not making mistakes and I was asking
myself what I'm doing wrong what is the
problem with me and maybe oh I need PhD
so of course I sign up for PhD at the
best university in my country
I'm about to finish that it took me a
lot of years I started to be gray I
changed the country and you know what
the problem is the same even though I'm
reading dear I'm reading politics I'm
reading and I'm able to like design
product strategy go to market a lot of
things and people are taking those idea
to the extreme that they are taking my
slides and removing my name
but problem is the same and I'm looking
still for the answer how to be like uh
heard by Bosses and anyone so I have
never been promoted to get the promotion
I always change the company that's why
10 years of experience like 12 companies
uh but uh like the the process that I
was having in my mind is that maybe I'm
just too nice to people because I'm a
giver I want to give you I want to do
things for you and maybe I'm just two
knives maybe I'm not using you know
something radical steps so I did a
tattoo shuriken that is showing me like
a ninja star that I can always be and do
something
maybe that will be categorized not nice
but maybe that's the way for other
people to hear me that I'm not that kid
anymore and I don't want to be treated
as a kid that I think that like it's not
inclusive to categorize by the age of
course and of course it's also not the
way to to say that but you see the point
that we should support each other not uh
make us and anyone else categorize and
also the last point I wanted to share is
that it's really rare to find a person
that will see in us something more that
they are so for example the manager is
hiring us or the boss is hiring us and
the maximum level of your career is
whatever the manager is and it's really
rare to find a leader who will see in
you something more and will grow you so
uh yeah I'm wishing you finding those
people I'm still looking for them
Katrina
the question was what gender specific
challenges stereotypes or barriers have
you had to overcome during your career
there have been a lot
and I learned I'm learning how to pick
my battles because if you try to slay
every battle you get exhausted you get
burned out
I love I pray when I go to a new company
please don't make any issues that I have
to deal with but there are going to be
issues and they are going to be
situations that you may have to draw the
Line in the Sand
uh just be true to yourself I've learned
I've learned that assess the situation
assess the culture try to find people to
be who will have your back you know and
but pick your battles
because you can't fight every battle
you'll be frustrated at yourself I've
had imposter syndrome I'll look at my
resume it's like I done this I did it
why am I here and I've done all this if
I was a man a white man they think I've
been walking water
so learn how to pick your battles
and find people that that you can talk
to who as a sounding board
you are great I'm great we're good
people we're good what we do
sometimes you pick the wrong person to
give you affirmation
as you know you're seeking that person
he's never ever going to give you
affirmation stop it you ain't gonna get
it no matter how good you are
find the person that give you the
affirmation that you need
keep that person like that and give that
person another person they need
affirmation from you be true for
forgiving malformation that's what fills
up the soul
it helps you ready for another day of
battle
but pick your battles
because if you don't you'll be so bitter
so burnt out that you will not want to
have anything to do with anybody so make
your battles
um early in my career I ended up in a
position where I was given a started to
get a lot of glue work which is work
that even as a technical woman you're
doing to hold your team together but
you're not getting credit for that work
it's it's extra things it's things
things around maybe helping schedule
meetings or bringing groups of people
together and it takes away time from
your technical deliverables and you get
no credit for it and so I fell into this
trap but being early career I kind of
threw myself into it I just want to do a
good job I want to make sure my manager
thinks I'm doing a good job and I'm
going to carry the full load of of all
of the things the glue work the
technical work all of the work and so
um this I think was
I I obviously don't know can't say for
sure but I I feel it was due to my age
and my gender that I was being asked to
do those things
um so one of the things I try to do now
that I lead a team is ensure that if
someone is if I'm asking someone to do
something that I'm clearly able to make
a value statement for it and that they
get credit for that work regardless of
what it is it's a Sim ticket that goes
onto their board because I need to be
able to say that they put time into it
it's time that they got through their
work to do it sometimes we all have to
work extra hours and and that's okay
it's not about that but it's about
saying I see that you were given
something to do it has value and we can
make a value proposition for it and this
is how I'm going to use it to advocate
for you later it could be it could be
around schedule a meeting for the team
to accomplish a specific purpose but
what was the purpose of that meeting it
wasn't that your value was that you
scheduled it your value is that you
facilitated the discussion you thought
about what ideas needed to be brought to
the board you wrote the doc afterwards
you did something and it matters and I'm
going to pull that together when it
comes to time for your promotion I'm
going to put a full package together
that helps show the complete depth of
your work and how you support this
organization so that's one thing and I
know lots of people here spoke about
outside of gender uh
issues and challenges they've faced I
remember being at a women in Tech
Conference in Portland Oregon and this
was again early in my career before I
landed my first job and I'm sitting at
the career fair I sit down in front of a
woman who's a recruiter and she looks at
me in the first question she asked me is
what's your Visa status and it was just
this moment where I realized that
someone doesn't see me the way I see
myself I'm like I was born here in
Portland Oregon like to like the
hospital two blocks from where this
conference is happening like I'm a
citizen I'm American like it just and in
the moment I was I was young and
flustered and I remember just like
I just wrapped up the conversation and I
walked away feeling so confused and I
think those moments sometimes when
you're the person delivering that you
don't you don't quite realize the impact
it has but it shook me for a week
feeling like oh my God like I I don't
think other people see me the way I see
myself and it's shocking and and I get
it I understand where maybe that
unconscious bias comes from but it
doesn't make it less impactful to the
person experiencing it either so
so thank you everyone with this uh we
conclude our questions for the planet